I will go back to a cartoon that was
published about 29 years ago in The New
Yorker. You might have seen it. It's the
one where two dogs are talking to each
other and one says to the other on the
internet, "No one knows you're a dog."
I would say, Michael, that the problem
that the Phil Steiner, the cartoonist,
shared with us back then is still here
today.
Pause for effect.
It's just getting worse because the
tools that are now freely openly
available like Chad GPT
and Midjourney and other things allow
kids that are 9 years old, I am not
joking now, to create fake IDs, fake
checks, fake anything you want,
including AI voice modulations of my
voice based video they found online from
somewhere I was interviewed. a video
like this and all of a sudden it is very
difficult for my bank, for my IT help
desk, for my mortgage company, for
anybody to know, are you talking to the
real Oryisen or to a perfect perfect AI
replicant?
I start my meetings with the magic
tricks cards.
>> I have one for you at the end. Why the
end? Start with it.
You want to do that?
>> Of course.
>> Okay.
>> We're This is all about social
engineering and and and the trickery of
deception of the mind.
>> Okay. So, you'll need to follow my exact
directions and we can start. Shuffle
them.
>> I'm ready.
>> Don't show me the cards. Shuffle them.
>> All right.
This is a first, guys. This is a first.
Never had this done. More than a
thousand episodes on 20-minute leaders.
Now it's been 30 episodes on the human
zero day. First time doing a live magic
trick.
>> Just make sure I don't see the deck that
no one will say, "Well, he saw you
show."
>> Good.
>> Yep.
>> Now, we're going to do a test run before
you do the real thing. Hold the deck
like this.
>> Yeah. Cut it anywhere you want. Again,
this is not the We'll do this again.
Just I want you to see now look at the
card that is there. It's still in your
hand.
>> What is it? Yeah. Tell us what it is.
Let's just say it was a six.
>> It is the fourth.
>> Fourth.
>> So now you're going to take put this
fourth on top
and you would put
>> four on top.
>> Say that when you do the real thing it
was a four. You're going to put the four
and you will put four more on top. So
that would be one, two, three, four. the
rest put on the bottom. And then at this
point, my job would be to guess what was
your card. Now remember, you're going to
shuffle it. I'm not going to see it.
You're going to cut it. I'm not going to
see it. You're going to see a number.
I'm not going to see it. You're going to
put it back and bury it with that
number. And that's when the magic trick
will begin for me. Get it? So now,
>> and you're going to guess both the
number and the type.
>> Yeah. Yeah. The the actual card. So you
can turn around, shuffle. I know it
sounds crazy. Turn around. So I can't
see doing
>> it ends up eight. Do I put eight cards?
>> That is correct. If it ends up a king,
you'll put 13 on top.
>> Good.
>> And ace, how many?
>> Uh, one. Ace will be one.
>> Got it. All right. I'm all shuffled up.
>> Okay. So now put it down so I don't see
it. Cut it. Put it on this. Yeah. Put it
there so no one can see. You're going to
cut. Only you will see the number. Yeah.
>> Here.
>> Okay. Look away. I'm I'm turning away.
>> Let's just say it was three. You're
going to put it back on top of that
thing. You're going to cover it with
three more. The rest put on the bottom.
And tell me when you're ready.
>> So, I'm putting the card on top and then
I'm putting the number of cards
associated with that number.
>> On top of that. Correct. So, if it was
four, you put the rest and the rest on
the bottom. Let me know when you're
ready.
>> I'm ready.
>> Okay.
>> We're going to go slow.
Tell me the first card.
>> Yeah.
>> What is it?
>> It's the ace of spades.
>> Tell me the second card.
>> It is the two of hearts.
>> Tell me the next card.
>> It is the ace of diamonds.
>> It is the five of spades.
Tell me the next card.
>> It is the four of diamonds.
>> Tell me the next card.
>> It is the two of clubs.
>> It is the eight of hearts.
>> Tell me the next card.
>> It is the five of hearts.
It is the nine of clubs.
>> Tell me the next card.
>> It is the king of spades.
It is the queen of spades.
>> Tell me the next card.
>> It is the six of diamonds.
It is the four of hearts.
>> Tell me one more card.
>> It is the six of hearts.
>> The card that you picked was the four of
diamonds.
>> That's impressive.
>> All right, we can talk about how you can
do this trick. I could be on a phone
call with you without even seeing you
and it would still work.
But I just showed you how in the mind of
a random random random person, they
think it's impossible for you to do
this, right? But hackers are better at
that. They understand patterns and they
can latch on to things that most people
would just think are meaningless. And
I'm sure I could get a 10 bucks from you
for this magic trick because you said
there's no way you can tell, right?
>> Absolutely. It's all about getting the
right information at the right moment.
Even if that information doesn't seem
like it's contributing something, if you
are on the other side have a good good
puzzle making, you got it.
>> Put it in the right context,
you can open a lot of doors. And with
that, Michael, let's begin
>> with that. We well we've already begun
Ori because you're today you're um
you're running an awesome company Troa
and you're building tools that
effectively are tackling
one of the most I think emerging
problems there are which is the
vulnerability of the human mind which is
what we just saw right the ability for
attackers to leverage AI in cyber
security contexts and not just AI social
engineering in general but now with AI
it's much worse and not you don't have
just experience as as a founder and CEO
of that but you al actually have
experience as a security professional
and you have experience on the on the
hacking side as well so gearing into the
conversation of human zero day attacks
tell me a little bit about your journey
how did how did we end up here and now
having this conversation
>> uh we ended up here and now first
because you were a very kind man who
decided to interview me. So I thank you
for that and I thank you for the
listeners uh who are here to hear the
insights we're about to share. I will go
back to a cartoon that was published
about 29 years ago in the New Yorker.
You might have seen it. It's the one
where two dogs are talking to each other
and one says to the other on the
internet no one knows you're a dog.
I would say, Michael, that the problem
that uh Phil Steiner, the cartoonist,
shared with us back then is still here
today.
Pause for effect.
It's just getting worse because the
tools that are now freely openly
available like Chad GPT
and Midjourney and other things allow
kids that are 9 years old. I am not
joking now to create fake IDs, fake
checks, fake anything you want,
including AI voice modulations of my
voice based off of some video they found
online from somewhere I was interviewed.
a video like this and all of a sudden it
is very difficult for my bank, for my IT
help desk, for my mortgage company, for
anybody to know are you talking to the
real Oryisen or to a perfect perfect AI
replicant. We are in that world. It's
just that most people think about chat
GPT as helping you write word documents
or No, no, no, no, no. We are like so
far beyond it that if you really
understand where the tools are and what
you can do with them, I could completely
have this conversation with an AI bot
that will respond to you based on
everything it thinks I might say, right?
It's probably not me, but that's where
we are. So, I think the identity is kind
of the last perimeter we will have to
wrestle with as a society.
And for that reason, I wake up every day
even though this is my fourth and
hopefully last startup. But I think if
we don't solve this, all this effort of
the internet will be for not because you
will simply not be able to believe is
this video real? Is this person real?
Did they really say that? We will be in
an endless cycle. And I hope what I'm
saying sound like what are you talking
about? We're already living in this
reality. And that is my point.
Wow. You know, we're um keep saying ori
but it's oral. Sorry. And I I I go back
to to this um history of cyber security
and and you'll appreciate it because
you've been you've lived through I think
much of it if not all of it. You know,
we started with you know the enterprise
firewall in '95. We transitioned to
malares with folks like Semantic in the
2000s. By 2008, we had more than I
believe 10 million malware permutations
running around. And then we had cloud
join in. And we had Palo Alto Networks
and today Whiz and then we had in 2015
Octa and identity security, but it was
in the context of the credentials and
the and the the au the written
authentication, the device
authentication.
And we had zero trust as a concept and
crowd strike coming in. And what we left
behind is the human. It's the human at
the end which is the front line that has
can install all of these amazing tools.
But if you can just say the right words
and look and sound the right way, all of
that uh can fall apart. And uh who
better than you to to know what can
happen there? If you don't mind, I'll
share with the audience a mental
construct to see how we got here based
on what you said because you're exactly
right.
Every single time we have developed yet
a new proxy, not proxy technical, but
proxy to the identity. Username and
password was a proxy to Michael. But if
I stole those, I became you. I gave you
an RSA token that became a proxy to you.
So if I steal that, I become you. I give
you certificates in your browser. Every
single time we have given something that
is a binary yes or no, we're basically
validating that you have a token or a
credential in your possession.
But we have never taken it to the next
step to say is Michael there? Let me
give you an example. You go to a hotel
room, you leave your laptop and your RSA
token in the room. The person who cleans
your room can easily now log in. Do you
agree?
But it's not that it was you.
>> And again, then people talk about
biometrics and face ID, Touch ID. But
that doesn't say it's Michael. It just
says that the fingerprint of whatever
phone this is just unlocked
mathematically, but we didn't have the
identity. What I'm saying is now we are
running out of options all the way.
Again, I'm the guy who invented device
fingerprinting. This was in the mid 90s
to the mid 2000s. Okay? And then I'm the
guy who led the pioneering of
passwordless authentication. Now you
call it phto and pasis. But Michael that
is not an identity still that is still a
proxy to I think it is you. My worry is
we are now living in a world
that with Genai and deep fakes if we
don't solve this last uh mile problem
the credentials are meaningless because
they are still not telling me that it's
you on the other end.
>> Right.
And uh and we were adding to the to this
picture that we've grown our reliance
over the last few years on biometrics.
My voice is my password. This is a new
phrase, right? This is not 20 years ago.
This is a 2020 phrase. as COVID hits and
everything becomes digitized and we have
this expectation that we won't go into
to the bank branch to open account or to
or to deposit a check and and and and
very quickly thereafter we have this
very similar technology but used in an
adversarial sense being able to clone
and and replicate it. Um, so, so, so
going back a little bit to your to your
history, talk to me about, um, all the
way back to device fingerprinting
because I really want to capture these
works of pioneering that you've led
because I think that'll give room and
the depth to the insights that you have
today on the way that human security
could and should be addressed moving
forward.
>> Okay. So for people who don't know uh my
history, I will say the high level is
I've spent some time being a fraud
investigator. This is in the late 90s
where e-commerce was just starting and
uh people were doing domain squatting,
right? So I started my career then I was
later on in a position to be the head of
risk at a very large credit card company
and I'll give you one insight from there
about how the crimes are the same. It's
just that they change technologies and
today I'm on the dark side. I'm in the
the vendor side or a partner if you are
nice. But the point is I have seen our
industry from multiple vantage points
and that gives me the ability to say
this when I was the head of risk at a
large credit card company. I was baffled
that we were using tokenization and
security and certificates like
everything Michael you would think is
like top-of-the-line you know uh RSA
whatever whatever right
and then I could see that the same
transactions were flowing again and
again and again and I know that it's
impossible because this transaction
happened let's just say at the large big
box store how can it happen 2 days later
again I mean it can't that's the
breaking the laws of physics so you get
on a plane you go to the place You
interview everybody and everything looks
normal until you go outside of the
building and you find a little device
that is literally with clippers tapping
the line, the phone line, Michael, of
them sending their transactions to us.
And the thing is just recording it so
later on you can replay it. Think about
what I just said in the line crypto
numbers, right? uh everything you can
imagine but nothing is asking wait a
second can I just sample it and replay
it if I invest all my energy in my voice
is my password and you Michael can
record it and simply replay it and that
will open the door what have we done
so I want you to see that the replay
attacks have happened in the physical
world even before they were online
fraud applications were done with pen
and paper before they were done online
account takeovers were done. Like all
these things that we think are like new
fancy exotic crimes, they're not. It's
just that the medium in which they
happen have changed and ergo the
technology. Jokingly I say to criminals
that I would interviews like you're like
old school. Why are you using guns? Like
you can do everything and more today
just with the browser. You don't need
there's no there's no need for blood
anymore. You're like you haven't
evolved. And the the lesson in all this
is to say you can't forget the past
because it can teach you a lot about the
MOS the modus operandi of how bad guys
think and work. For that uh reason I
work with people like Frank Abnell from
catch me if you can and Kevin Mitnik may
you rest in peace uh and other hackers
because they're thinking unlike us like
they can see the magic trick I did with
you and say this is how he did it in a
nancond. Why? Cuz their brain is
thinking differently. But if you see how
the old school guys did it and now just
translate that to the internet, you will
see that in every single decade, we were
fighting the same exact thing, but we
never got to solving it. We never solve
the who is the true persona. Like who is
the person there? Not their handwriting,
not their pen, not their certificate,
like all those other proxies we talked
about. So unless we solve it, Michael,
we will be here 5 years from now, you
and I still complaining. Why is it not
solved?
Wow. Okay. So, here we are. It's 2024.
It's almost 2025, which is quite
disturbing because uh it's uh the time
is time is moving and and things are
running. Um it's been slightly over 2
years, well just just about 2 years
since the uh anniversary of the Chad GPT
launch. um a little bit more since the
launch of Medjourney and Dolly and uh
and and and so we're we're kneede into
this new world of Genai and the
evolution of these attacks. What what
are you seeing in your seat? What is
happening? How are hackers using these
using tools today to hack the human
mind? Okay. So, I'll if if we ever had a
history book of our space, it would look
something like this. From 1964, the
invention of the password to 1995,
you 2FA was not a thing. You just had
username password. Okay. From 1995, RSA
secure token. By the way, I'm not an RSA
fan. Let me just say it for the record.
I'm using them because they did create a
watershed moment to say username and
password are static. Ergo, they could be
stolen or breached. So now we need
something that is dynamic, right? So
that was a watershed moment. And then we
take it all the way to the mid 2000s
where you start seeing things like SMS
OTP. So not necessarily a token that you
hold. You'd get email OTP, you would get
biometrics, all those things that again
augmented to a FA in a different way.
And to about 200 I'll say 1516 where
passwordless became like when the the
pho alliance began working. So that's
another 10 years of work to create
passwordless and the next watershed is
exactly the moment you talked about
Michael the day chat GPT came out in the
history books will uh append everything
we have done let me give you some
examples of what we see now in the wild
and I'll say it again done by children
not a nation state
a if I was a Nigerian prince sender of
emails
I can now do what? I can load my very
bad English content and make it sound
not just correct grammatically and
synthetically.
I can ask chat GPT to make it more
convincing.
You can literally do that. So now if you
and I said, "Yeah, I can always spot
these fishing emails because look, they
don't even know how to write English."
That went away.
Number two, I can now imitate language
style of my boss if I scanned enough of
his I actually know how he uses what
word he uses to sign his emails and it
would not be like a generic thing. So
that is being taken away from us. The
third is you can sample now one face. I
don't know if you've seen these
softwares that take a a picture and
creates a video out of it. So you don't
even need a video of me to kind of look
like me, right? And the last one is
voice.
What did I just say? I said that if I
was doing a spear fishing attack on I'm
just going to say Stephen Spielberg
in the wild. Michael, I have enough
sampling of his image, video, voice,
data, writing. His banker will never
know it's not him writing him. Never.
Because it would look so it's almost
like the LLM was fed with him. So of
course the output would be him. We are
now living in a world where anything you
get that is purportedly for me, you can
literally suspect and say, "How do I
really know it's from you?"
That is where we are because these tools
are generally available for goodness.
Don't get me wrong, I love AI, but in
the wrong hands, man oh man, we are
robbing ourselves from the ability to
detect the fraud.
So our human ability to detect fraud is
is quite limited. And
then you turn to defense systems, right?
And
>> you know I I I I I wasn't a I wasn't in
a in a mature enough cognitive state
back then. But when malware came into
the operating system world, I'm sure
that Semantic would have said or did
say, "Yeah, well, we don't expect people
to open up the the bits and these
software. We will scan the the we will
scan the code. We will scan the packets
and we will find signatures of the
malicious attributes of these pieces of
software and to and and lo and behold
today you must have what 30 or 40 known
financially backed companies
looking at creating this antivirus if
you will approach to to the problem that
you're describing. Yeah, you have a
slightly you you do have thoughts on
that. I recall from previous
conversations we've had. Um what what's
limiting in this in this way of
approaching it?
>> It is reporting yesterday's weather.
That's the problem with it. Meaning
that as long as we are talking about
signatures and not uristics, I can only
tell you ah we've seen this in the labgo
it's bad. I cannot by design tell you
this thing that you're looking at even
though we've never seen it in the lab is
bad because it shows it exhibits the
behavior of something bad even though we
haven't seen it and that would be the
uristic site. So the the whole world of
signatures of malware is just like yes
it's good but it's like telling you what
happened yesterday. It is not really
really really protecting you from the
new attack. Then came uristics that says
listen I don't care who touches the
kernel right and in what way as long as
the tur the kernel is touched by a
process that is not approved we have a
problem so that's a better way to kind
of abstract the problem so yes we did
that but what's the problem the
operating system doesn't know like
riverside this software by the way I'm
not uh promoting riverside I'm just
giving it as an example Michael asked me
to download the software today so we can
have this recording. Now, my OS this
morning didn't know I'm going to do it.
So, it can say, "Whoa, whoa, whoa. What
is this Riverside doing?" And in fact,
my Mac says, "This is from the internet.
Are you sure you want to run it?" So,
because we can't tell what tomorrow
brings, you really can't do a lockdown
system that says everything that I
haven't seen before ever go bad. So, you
see that will be not good. And now we're
in this wedge of what can malware do
between what I need my system to do and
what is bad.
If you bring the genai and I think this
is why you're in your business, Michael
is I don't know what the next video will
show. I I honest you don't know what
what your next thought it's going to be
and yet people want to buy from you a
solution to tell them is this real or
not even though they know in their heart
of hearts you have never seen it. That
to me is the hardest thing we will have
to face as a society. who gets to say
what's real and what's not in a world
where we haven't seen the attack yet.
>> Right now, this problem then opens up to
many many different contexts and use
cases. And you mentioned, you know,
we're going beyond in here just the the
enterprise and security breach where
we're, you know, you're already talking
about this is perhaps one of the big
biggest problems that the world will
face. And and by the way, I fully agree
with you. I think that the ability for
us to to continue operating in a digital
environment as we already are and and
assume and and so much of the so much
percentage of the information we take in
as humans is now digitized and that
disruption is just it's like pulling a
rug that I don't know what will replace
it. But we're getting ahead of ourselves
because um I I do want to focus now on
on situations in which we do have some
level of control over the interaction
particularly
um the context of businesses and how
humans are susceptible and vulnerable
within the business context where how
where do you see humans being vulnerable
in in a business environment or a
business interaction?
>> I'll give you a couple of cases.
uh without mentioning the actual casino
in the Las Vegas strip. One of them took
a phone call in their IT help desk and
we're convinced that it's an employee
talking to them. Reset their password
and the rest is malware is being or
ransomware. Pick your jargon of today
and then the whole system of the entire
resort is down and until you pay the
ransom, you're you're not back. So
here's a simple case. I pick up the
phone, I'm in the help desk, I want to
help and I cannot tell Michael who is
calling me.
So that's one. Let me give you another
example. Imagine
>> by the way, I think if anybody if
anybody just Googles
the sentence casino
>> a ransomware
>> ransomware spider attack,
>> you'll find exactly the casino name and
you'll find also how much damage is
perceived to be there. I can't even
count the number of digits in that in
that number. But it's
>> just to give you a number because they
were down four days. If you just take
down what they were accounting if they
were up, it's $100 million just for that
period. Okay, let me give you a couple
more examples. I call my bank and I say,
"Hey, I would like to move some money."
How the heck do they know who just
called them? By by what means will they
know it's me? So, we ruled out my voice
is my password because it could have
been recorded or made by modulator off
my voice.
Uh, after this, Michael, I do have a
demo for you if you want to see how I'm
emulating David Atenboro's voice. And
even his mom will not be able to say
it's not him. I can show it to you
because I had to show my board. Why are
we building this? I said like because
you cannot tell me who just talked to
you. You just can't.
I have I have to see it. I love David.
>> Okay. And I also have it for Snoop Dog
for people who don't know who David
Appenboro is.
>> Okay. So, we can do that, right? But
I'll show you. I It took me a day to
program it just to show you AI in the
hands of a kid. You can do anything you
want almost. So, just to wrap up the use
cases, IT help desk. We talked about I
call my bank. How the heck do they know
who's talking to them? Say that you buy
a house and you put uh all the money in
escrow and the day before the close
somebody calls the escro company and
says, "Hey, I just got a new bank
account. Could you please wire the money
over there?"
How would they know who they're talking
to by what means?
And it goes on and on and on. HR, how do
you know who's interviewing with you? Uh
if you're a VC, how do you know that
it's your limited partner calling to
tell you something? You just don't know.
And I'm I'm I'm saying it's a phone call
not because it's the problem with the
call. You could send an email that we
both know that with BEC business email
that that is a dead deal anyway, right?
So it's like by what means will you know
that it's really me and I think you now
you should open your eyes to realize oh
my god we're all exposed. We live in a
world as if this didn't this meaning
chat GPT and GI didn't happen. But we're
in it already.
I mean, we we're all annoyed by the way
that these systems are the the agents
are refusing to let us in until we tell
them our dog's name and and the and the
social and the last four digits of the
social security account and and the last
name of my of my of my fifth grade
teacher who I recall forever. It's Mrs.
Nolock. And I know that because she is
my you you Miss Nolock are my security
password for so many things. that I'm
going to change it right after.
>> I hope so because now all of us know
what your code is.
>> Exactly. No, no, I I I did change it a
few years ago. But but you were a strong
inspiration. I now changed it to a
different teacher from a different year.
Um but why is that not good enough?
Because that is good information that
they ask me and I tell them.
>> Um okay, put on your seat belts.
especially if you're a student in
university. I find this to be a uh
controversial topic, but I'm going to
say what I'm going to say. We all want
our privacy. Me included. And we say
that we want our privacy, right?
However, if you go check your Facebook
or your Instagram or your social media,
you just told the world where you had
dinner last night.
Hm.
>> You might have told them your favorite
vacation spot right there and you may
have used it as your KBA, your knowledge
based authentication. So on one hand, we
say we want privacy and at the same time
we use the things that we literally
advertise to the world like your dog's
name, Michael,
in social media.
And not everybody is smart enough to go
limit her social media to just her
friend. Let me just be honest about. So
if I'm an attacker and I wanted to guess
if you have kids or you have a birthday,
let me just give you some t again. Don't
try this at home kids because I don't
want you to go to jail. But this is how
a professional would do it. First, we
would pick a target that is a CEO for a
publicly traded company. Why?
Because by law in the annual book, they
must say their name,
their middle name, if there is one. They
must say their uh how old they are so
you know what year they were born. They
have a signature literally in black and
white camera ready for you to pick up.
Should I continue?
We are literally advertising this to the
world and then we expect when the check
comes from the CEO to only be by his
hand. Really
there I just opened your eyes to how a
hacker looks at the same thing we all
look at and think how can I use it to my
advantage right back into the identity.
If we keep doing what we're doing,
advertising our secrets, right? And you
ask, "What's wrong with it?" What's
wrong with it is a, it's static. B, it's
breachable. C, you might tell it
yourself to the world. And it's not
something that is really proving to me
that it's Michael. It's an attribute of
Michael. But knowing my date of birth
does not mean that it's me who gave it
to you
there. And and I don't want people to be
afraid to go to the ATM after listening
to this. Even though if I were you, I
would definitely think twice about going
to the ATM there. Why? Because it's a
junction of where people exchange money
and codes and pins. And if you are a
hacker, you would wait for good people
there. It's it's how this work. I mean,
you rob banks because that's where the
money is, right?
So AI, you've been you've been um I
guess not skeptical, but you've been
living at the a world where these this
credentialbased world is not is not the
right environment for for authentication
for a while. In fact, for for something
like eight years, nine years,
>> I would say KBA started 20 years ago
because companies
against them, but companies who
aggregate data about what credit cards
you have, what addresses you lived in,
you know, those kind of questions assume
that only Michael would know the answers
to these. But today, we know for sure
that bad guys would actually answer this
better than you.
>> That's why it's bad. because it's not a
an arbiter of the truth,
>> right? And so and specifically you've
been looking at passwordless
authentication
>> with your current company Trersona. So
so tell me a little bit about this
journey as an entrepreneur which which
took also an interesting twist
and so so tell me a little bit about
Tresona.
>> So this is my fourth startup. I sold my
last company in 2013 which specialized
in device fingerprinting and detecting
fraud in the e-commerce and the banking
and the airline world. And the reason we
needed those technologies is because
when your credit card was presented to
buy something, I couldn't tell for sure
is Michael there popping up his card or
somebody breached it, right? Which is
the same exact problem.
So after exiting that company,
>> I sat and thought, what should we do
next? Like what's the next problem? And
I went up to Silicon Valley to speak
with my former investors, Cliner
Perkins. And they said a few things to
me that really caused me to sit and
ponder
what like think about it. You don't have
20 startups in you, Michael. You have
just like three or four maybe because
each one is a bet of seven to 10 years.
And they told me, "Listen, buddy. This
is probably your last one."
So, think hard. Like, what what should
your legacy be? Like, what do you like?
You already done very well with the
device fingerprint. What? This could be
the last thing you do. So, it better be
like bold. Like, you know what a behag
is big hairy audacious gold. And I said,
"Well, I really don't know what it is."
And they said, "Listen, we expected you
not to know because you're not hungry as
you were. That that's what happens to
entrepreneurs that exit. The the money
part of it goes down. I'm not going to
lie to you.
But the ambition or what you really want
to put a dent in the universe is still
there. So it took me four months,
Michael, to really sit and think if I
got on the horse one more time, what
would I want to see different? Like
what's the thing that I would want to
change? And when I got back to them and
I said, "Let's get rid of passwords,"
they all laughed.
They they basically say, "We can't fund
you. This is like too it's too out
there. Like it will never happen." And I
said, "But why?
And if you're a VC, you think about your
investments in term of vintages, like
what could happen in 3 years, 5 years, 7
years, 10 years. You don't think about a
20 years. They just that's not how they
operate. And they were under the
impression that to make this dent in the
universe, which is not small, will take
so long and so much money and effort
that it's just not for them. Like it's a
government project, right? But not a VC
project. It's And by the way, they're
not crazy. Those guys are the best
investors there are.
So I went back to the drawing board and
I said this. Okay guys, what if we did
this? What if we offered the world a way
to wean themsel off of passwords? And of
course some people would go for it, some
people would not, but we would do it in
a way that is with a time horizons of 5
to 10 years. And they said, but how?
And now came the question of the
implementation and how you go do it. So
in 2015,
uh, Trona was born and let me tell you
the how. The how was this.
We developed the world's first and still
only insured authentication. What does
that mean? I would win you off with
username and password. That's what you
will need to do as a user. And then when
you authenticate with the system we gave
you, if we are wrong and it's not
Michael Matias, you get a million bucks
every time. Simple.
Why? Because every software vendor says,
"I'm the best. I'm the best." Right?
Everybody says that. So, as a buyer, how
the heck do you know what's what's
better? But there was only one that
says, "If I'm wrong, you're getting a
million bucks." And it was backed not by
our money or the VC. It was backed by
the largest insurance company.
>> Yes.
>> Wow. This How'd you get that happen? We
can spend another hour just on that,
Michael, but you can go see a press
release in 2016 because we were a year
in stealth mode to build the world's
first and only insured authentication.
It required you to do the right thing.
But it wasn't for everybody because if
my mom calls the bank just to ask for
the balance, you don't need the system.
But if I call the New York Stock
Exchange and want to delist myself,
don't you really want to know that
you're talking to the company? If I call
Fedwire, if I call the Swift account, if
I call uh you know how Twitter had an AP
tweet that the president was hurt and
the stock market went, you know what I'm
talking about? That is why it's like we
suggested to Twitter to protect all the
important accounts with this kind of
level of security that you really know
who you're talking to and let me know
what happened. Michael, you should ask a
simple question. How come we're not all
using it?
>> Yeah. Well, how come?
>> So, the reason is this.
We as a society did not suffer enough
pain in this thing we call the internet
to make us move to do something
to secure ourselves. This is the
reality. Why? Because every time I
provided to uh large healthcare
companies, banks, even our own Pentagon,
I'm not joking. The push back Michael
was like, "Ah, do I really need to carry
this token with me? Do I really need to
show you my driver license? Do I really
need like it? You understood that the
pain of living with this crutch we have
and really solving it had a chasm I
guess. So what did we do? I'm an
entrepreneur still. Two years into it
realizing, wow, people are not buying it
because they think there's too much
friction. I said, you know what? How
about we'll get rid of the token? You
don't need that. But you don't get now
the million dollar insurance. Get it?
Because And guess what happened,
Michael? We got our first order. I'm not
joking.
And we lived two years like that. And I
asked the It was a healthcare company. I
said like, "Uh, I see that you bought
this system just for your doctors, like
for HIPPA compliance. Why didn't you buy
it for your 80 million consumers? Oh,
because we think that the the scanning
thing that you have, it's kind of taboo.
So, if you could get rid of that, we
will give it to everybody." So, guess
what we did? We took that out. It's
almost like an onion. We can't. And we
got our second big order. Get it? People
say they want security, but they're not
willing to do the next thing to get it.
>> How did you balance though? Because you
had these layers of onion for the
security. That was the solution that
enabled you to replace the passwords.
So, I guess it's not as simple as, oh,
they don't like the driver license.
Let's get that. Let's go.
>> No, no, no. It is as simple as that, but
it's not as secure, but it's easier to
use. And now the marketing and people
say, "Yeah, we can give that to our
customers cuz it doesn't look like
you're doing something uh very and guess
what? We landed with a system that
basically has your browser telling the
server who it is." Very similar to using
password just like you did not need to
type it. And man, that's how
passwordless was born. It was not born
out of zero to that. It was born out of
the most secure system in the world.
Insured to a million bucks. Shaved.
Shaved. shaved to meet the market where
it is. Now, let me look straight at the
camera. If you're an entrepreneur, don't
think about your idea as being great.
I'm sure it's great. Ask your customers
if they think it's great.
Yeah. Meet the market where it is, not
where you hope they would be. So, I'm
here 8 years in, Michael, selling a
thing that I would be ashamed to sell on
year one because that is not really
solving the problem. But it will take us
from here slowly over time to where the
world needs to be. But the reason we're
not there is simple. We simply have not
experienced enough pain as a society. We
can talk about what that pain looks like
if you care. But we simply didn't
experience it to say, you know what,
we're not doing another day like with
those passwords. We need something
better. We didn't reach that pain point.
Now, it sounds like, by the way,
incredible lessons not just on human
security, but on entrepreneurship as
well. And I'm listening with with with
high high focus here. You've it what
sounds to me and and in a second I'll
ask you what happened to Tersona in the
last two years. Um because it it feels
like you you taking your own advice you
did and and continuing with the same
vision you or the same impact on society
you did find an area where the pain is
acute enough to enact a significant
change in a process in human behavior.
So so what what's happened the last two
years besides deep fakes going h going
haywire? So, uh, that casino that I
mentioned is one of the best things that
ever happened to us. I hate the fact to
say it that you need a disaster, uh, for
change to happen. But there's a saying,
don't let a good crisis go to waste.
Right.
>> I am now talking to CISOs every week,
Michael. every week who tell me verbatim
I am losing sleep
over being the next victim of this
because I know that with all my array
all my battery of defenses this is the
one thing I have nothing for I do not
know who's calling me with 100% sure
and because of that fear now you're
willing to exchange fear with change of
behavior
product market fit
I couldn't have done it three years ago,
couldn't have done it 5 years ago,
couldn't have done it eight years ago
for this reason because people would say
either the threat of the voice sound too
similar would sound like exotic to them.
But now with Jennai, it's obvious.
So the fear of what's going to happen
and the fact that it already happened
and somebody is now bringing people
together to say, "Okay, this is not a
joke. I really need to deal with it."
And now they're willing to trade doing
the document scan remotely which was
taboo before with oh my god I now
understand that without it all my other
tests are like not really good and those
are my best prospects people who have
internalize the problem other people are
waiting other people are trying
different things but there is a time
Michael where again in the future don't
don't want to predict that every single
company will use additional methods of
listen carefully identity verification
ation
beyond authentication and tofa and
certificates and all those things we
have been using will be deemed machine
to machine authentication or machine to
user uh static authentication which we
all know how to beat. This will become
like the next perimeter which is the
identity itself and after that we will
not go back because we will know that
without it you really don't know who's
on the other end
>> like the what you're talking about is
effectively is it's the physical human.
It's sort of the the question of are you
the physical being of Michael on the
other side of the line, right?
>> The the carbon form now in person, I can
literally check your eye. I can take
your fingerprint. I mean, we can do a
lot of things in in-person identity
proofing. Like when you walk into the
Pentagon, you can do a lot of things
that you can't do online. But I'm not
kidding myself. You're going to log into
Gmail. You're going to go to your online
banking for the next 50 years. So, it's
not like we say, "Oh, unless it's in
person, I'm not going to authenticate
you." But to make the best
authentication remotely, you will need
to use these additional tools that were
not there before. And I'm prepping the
David Etenbor thing just so you can have
it and later on you can do it as extra
content if you want. We don't have to do
it, but I really want to shake people up
to say how easy it is. You want to do
it? Let's do it.
>> All right, Michael. Um,
let's do this. I will set up a recording
uh in 20 minutes with you. We will do
just that. I just want you to see I have
the app.
>> Let me see if I can You see David Asenbo
here on the camera. It's called Narrate
Your Life
>> and and I just need to resido it because
it expired here. But I I will do it with
you in about 20 minutes and then we'll
do it as extra content after this.
>> I love it. I love it. Okay, so
>> Ori the the space of of you know the
question of identities has been around
for a while, right? Octa 2015 zero trust
policies. I mean this this idea of
identity verification. And I think today
there's hundreds of different companies,
vendors that are offering, you know,
identity verification, know your
customer onboarding, even scan the
document, take a selfie, we'll match,
we'll we'll figure everything out. Why
is that not good enough? We we they're
making huge business. It's these are
billion-dollar businesses.
>> Yeah. And I have to be very careful with
what I say just because I meet those
people in trade shows and I don't want I
don't want to be ambushed but as a
practitioner
I will say this again put on your seat
belt because I I used to be the head of
risk. I have to think about it in in
those uh terms. I will also say don't
try this at home because I'm giving you
a recipe of how to break those things.
Okay.
So here's my driver license. I'm
covering it on purpose and it has a fun
picture of me.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> When we say the world the words selfie
match, let's be exact. What we're saying
is we're asking a computer to take a
picture with one camera here
and hoping that it will be my driver
license like the back camera. And then
I'm turning the camera to the front to
say now take a picture of the person.
And now we're asking an algo, hey, is
mathematically these two faces match.
That's what we are doing. And that's
what good people do, Michael, because
they want to open their account.
But do you agree mathematically that if
I were to replace the image here with uh
Brad Pitt?
Yeah.
>> And then when the camera flips,
I will put the same Brad Pitt. Now from
this edge it will not be my real face.
It will be this. Do you agree that
mathematically these two faces will
match.
>> But then you have livveness, don't you?
>> Well, in a minute we'll get there. I'm
taking you step by step just to see the
concept.
>> Okay. Okay.
Yes. Mathematically those the pixels
will match. You'll you'll mathematically
the metric the Yes. Exactly.
>> Good. Now let's go to step two.
livveness. I'm going to take out
scissors.
Livveness in the computer world can be
measured a few ways.
One of them has to do with, don't ask me
how I know this, with your eyelids. Cuz
humans blink.
So you take a piece of paper,
you cut out one eye,
you then cut out another eye.
You know that even kids can do this.
This is not something that you need a
nation state.
And if I print a picture of Brad Pitt
and cut these eyes and take this pen and
do this, Michael, watch
to the computer. This looks like he
blinked.
>> Wow.
>> Try it at home. I just told you how it's
done. Wait, there is a third generation.
Apple generates two cameras, so it will
be stereophonic. So it can you Great. I
know how this works.
You take the same piece of paper and
again don't try this at home. You take a
pillow. You curve it on a pillow and
tape it to a t-shirt. I can show you
literally picture of the underground how
they do it. And now it's Brad Pit 3D
because no one will say it's not 3D and
blinking. And you just bypassed
our AI detection for livveness and for
being there 3D, Michael, because that's
another test you can do. Should we go
forward?
>> Absolutely.
>> Enough with it. Enough. Enough with it.
Like you cannot ask a phone with an ALGO
to detect what somebody like Kevin
Mitnik or Frank Abino would do because
you can go back. Remember our example
with the um signatures of malware. You
can tell me what was done before, but
you can't tell me what they're going to
do tomorrow when they turn on a dime
because the AI has not seen it yet.
>> Absolutely.
>> That is the problem. So I'm not saying
don't use it. I'm not saying it doesn't
work, but I'm saying it is more good
friction for good people than really
catching fraud at this point in time.
>> Absolutely.
>> Sorry. I'm going to tell the truth
whether you like it or not.
>> Fully fully fully convinced here. So,
>> and I can show you examples from the
underground. Again, I have them with me,
but I don't like to show them usually
just because I don't want to give would
be criminals ideas. Oh, so that's how
you do it. I don't need to go to school
tomorrow. I can do this. That's the
reason why I just don't advertise it. If
you are in the underground, you can go
see methods of how this is done today.
>> So, so what so with taking all your
experience and all your knowledge, what
what do we resort to? Because you
because with all with everything you're
saying, you're it's you're not saying
here we're we're giving up, right? You
I'm not hearing you say that. I'm not
hearing you say h we have no way of
working digitally because you would have
said that already sometime in the in the
last 15 minutes.
So, so what so what do we do?
>> Okay, so we need to identify in every
transaction that we are uh doing what is
the level of risk involved. Let me give
you some lowrisk things getting a
library card.
You don't need what I just said. You
don't need livveness test because the
the worst that can happen is that
somebody will get a library card that
they shouldn't. Big deal. Not a problem.
Okay.
>> Absolutely.
>> However, however,
the E911, let's just define that as a
term,
is an adversary logging into a water
treatment plant. Note, I didn't say
nuclear. I just said water treatment
plant that every city in America has.
and just change fiddle with the knobs
with the ratio of you tell me chlorine
fluoride whatever we put in the water
and now you have a serious problem of
your hand.
>> Let me give you another example.
You can Google this already has happened
in upstate New York. I'm giving you
enough keywords to go search. If an
adversary of the United States logs into
a dam
and fiddles with the knob, you can drown
10,000 people in one day.
Those kind of transactions, Michael, you
should not use username and passwords
for. Do you see? So, I know how we think
about the internet as a thing or the
digital life as a thing, but it's not a
thing. It is a cascading chain of
transactions in different levels of risk
and uh outcomes. All I'm saying is this.
You want to get a password reset for an
account, you need to use something that
gets down to the identity. You want to
move a million bucks again because of
terrorists and all that, you need to use
something that is better than just
static credentials. But to post on
Facebook on a private account, not on
the New York Times account, you can do
it because the worst that can happen,
you fooled 500 people who are your
friends, the world will not end. That is
what I'm saying. We can keep living. But
if we get to the point where an
adversary or somebody bad proves to us
that the security level we assumed for
consumers is also good for like
administrative uses, man, we will be in
an E911 before we wake up. And I just
don't want that to happen. But I'm also
tired as a person. You can go read all
my writing of saying this is going to
happen unless we kind of act. But if you
ask me, Michael, I'm now in my mid-50s.
I've learned a few things in life.
People buy insurance after the flood.
That's the reality. It's the Cassandra
syndrome, if you know what that is. You
can talk to customers, you can talk to
people all day long until you're blew in
the face. But I assure you, the minute
they get scratched, okay, how much is
it? Blank check. a day before that no
I'm not sure I need this. We cannot
change that as entrepreneurs and it's
part of the business plan that if you're
listening to this you need to realize
however logical you think it is it does
not mean the market will agree with you.
>> So are you only selling today find or
finding success in selling to those that
are that are hacked with with these
types of attacks? Is that so is that the
go in motion?
>> No. So, oh my god, you're asking the
question. So, uh if you were uh working
with me, nobody works for me, by the
way. People work with me, you would know
that one of the things I constantly say
to our team, we are not ambulance
chasers. That we cannot be, we're not,
we won't be. Period. What does that
mean? That the minute I hear about a
hack in the news, I call the company,
hey, I have something for you. Don't do
that.
But what I am saying is people who have
been burnt Michael are more susceptible,
>> more open and might reach out to you. So
those are the easy targets. But you
don't want to build a business case
based on that because it's happen
stance.
Uh the go to market we have is a to tell
people here are some free transactions
and I want you to see what's the magic
there. The magic is a I'm not selling
you anything. I'm giving it to you
because if I truly believe in the vision
and the mission
I want to see a safer internet. So I'm
giving you something. Just use it. Don't
pay me. Just use it. But if I give it to
you for free and you don't use it, you
see it doesn't matter cuz clearly you
won't pay. So we start by giving some
free stuff just to build the uh the
street creds that we're not here for the
money. We're here to solve the problem
>> and you're creating and later on you can
decide to pay.
That's our go to market.
>> Beautiful.
>> If you will use it, Michael, without
paying me, I'm still a happy man cuz
that means I had a vision and a mission
to go fix this issue.
>> I love it. I love it.
and and and I'm sure that after all
after hearing the complexity and and and
the growth here, are you are you willing
to share also the the the thoughts of of
how you can protect these high valued uh
these highvalued transactions or these
these user authentications and and I do
encourage anybody to go to trona and and
try this out. It is open. you you ran a
demo with me just uh just just a while
before and it's and it's really really
impressive.
>> I would say this. First of all, thank
you for the plug. I didn't ask for it,
but it's very kind of you. If anybody
who listens to this want to go see how
it's done and play with it for free,
it's there. But if you're in a position
of power, as in you're an IT director,
you're a CISO, you are working in a call
center, you're a fraud investigator,
show this to your team to ask, "How do
we know who just called us to move the
100,000 airline miles?" We don't. And
account takeover is one of the things
that this thing solves. You'd be amazed
how much power you would have, even if
you're not the CEO of a company, to
affect change just because you bring
people to the knowledge. So, if you
could do one thing out of this chat is
go do some self exploration and see what
Michael is talking about. And again,
there's no money involved. You can just
get there and start using it. There's no
contract, no credit card. We just just
use it.
I would say this, look at all the
transactions in your company and kind of
all lot them into this will not do
anything. This might be risky, but these
are the things we really have to
protect. and go protect them with real
security that goes all the way to the
identity. Passwords are just not good
enough, unfortunately.
Absolutely.
And so with that, I'm I'm going to leave
uh people to just go to Tersona and and
they try it. And again, I think I was I
I I was truly truly impressed. And uh
and what what I was truly impressed with
I think what what came across is your
true understanding of the landscape and
and aiming to build a product that deres
that drives real value quickly. Um the
simplicity of it besides the onboarding
and the free model that's of course
important but but it's this it was the
simplicity and the and the the
contextual understanding of how people
would operate with it which was uh which
was impressive and and I think is
solving a very very important problem
and and your and and your your comments
on the complexity of of the evolving
space and the complexity of of treating
this place as a malware and as a
yesterday problem. But you know this
show is all about human zero day and
it's all about we're we're entering into
a world where the zero day attacks on
humans are evolving at a rate which I
don't think we can even measure because
of the breadth the variety the variance
the the sophistication the motivation
the Frank Abigales of the world that are
now that now have a a a play-doh to play
with with all this Genai work. Um is and
and in a world which has become just
infinitely digitized and you know you
remember you you shared you shared like
eight or nine use cases for areas where
there's high value transactions with
highly privileged users.
>> That's a lot. Yep.
>> That's a that's like so much of what we
do.
>> Yeah. So let's do this. Michael. Um,
after we finish this recording, I will
provide you a couple of links. One to
the casino attack we talked about, one
of them to the state-ofthe-art of uh how
Genai makes driver licenses. And we will
also do a separate recording as bonus
material of my demo of David Atenboro
narrating any picture you will pick. So
that's your homework, Michael. you just
like you started with a magic trick that
I've never seen. You're gonna pick a
picture that you've never ever shared
with me, something fun, and in the demo,
you'll send it to me and we will have
David Atenboro in one minute narrate it
site unseen. As you can see, I couldn't
have possibly prepared for it and you
will have to answer the question. Would
you know that it's not David Atenboro
and it's just it will blow your mind.
So, we'll do that as extra content after
this.
>> I love it. Ori, thank you so much for
being here. Truly appreciate it. That
was wonderful. Thank you.
Thank you. And happy Thanksgiving to you
and your family.
>> Thank you, too.